EDDIE KAY: I'd like to introduce
John Fox, who is a
Harvard Ph.D. anthropologist,
who has excavated ancient ball
courts in Central America,
traced Marco Polo's route
across China, and bicycled
Africa's Rift Valley in search
of human origins.
He has contributed commentary
to Vermont Public Radio, has
written for "Smithsonian,"
"Outside," and "Salon," among
other publications, and in 2010
was awarded a MacDowell
Colony Fellowship.
He is also the author of "Around
the World With a
Million Kids: Adventures of an
Online Explorer," a collection
of essays written while
co-leading the groundbreaking
Quest Interactive Educational
Expeditions.
Please join me in giving a
warm welcome to John Fox.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN FOX: All right, thanks
very much, Eddie.
And thank you all for
coming today.
And anybody that is remote,
hopefully you can hear me and
see me as long as I stay
in my box over here.
So, great to come
here and talk.
I have to say thanks, first of
all, to Google, because I used
Google extensively in
researching this book--
particularly Google Books, which
I never realized until I
actually had a book project
myself to write what an
extraordinary resource
that is.
So kudos to all you guys do.
It's definitely a huge help.
So first a little background on
how this book came to be.
It started, interestingly, with
a question that my son
asked me when he was 7.
He is now 12, and he's
still as fanatic
about sports as ever.
I was living in Vermont
at the time--
had not moved to Boston yet--
and it was a spring day.
It was Red Sox season.
It was one of the seasons
where they were actually
winning from the get-go,
which was good.
It was a good spring.
And we were playing catch
in the backyard--
really sort of typical
father-son scene--
and my precocious son stops, and
he says, hey Dad, why do
we play ball, anyway?
It was one of these kind of
existential questions that
kids tend to ask at that
particular age-- sometimes
maddening, but always
intriguing.
And it kind of stuck with me.
As the play went on, the
moment passed, he got
distracted by other things,
and that was that.
But for me it kind of stuck.
And the reason it stuck was
years before, as a graduate
student in anthropology, I had
done research on an ancient
game played by the Maya and the
Aztec in Central America.
And I'd written a dissertation
that
probably five people read--
maybe six.
And I'd spent time in the wilds
of Honduras excavating
these ancient stadiums that I'll
talk a little bit more
about and became captivated
by that subject.
But I had set it aside, done
other writing and other work,
and the years had moved on.
But his question sparked a new
interest in the topic.
And it kind of broke it open
in the way that kids can do
that, because it took it from
a kind of esoteric, academic
subject to something much bigger
and philosophical.
Why do we play ball?
Why do we play the
games we play?
How did we get to the games we
play today in terms of the
history of these games?
And ultimately, why do they
mean so much to us?
Why are we so unbelievably
obsessed and
captivated with them?
So that set me off on a
journey-- literally--
around the world and through
time exploring a lot of the
games we're familiar with
and some that we're not.
So today I'm going to whip you
through the centuries and
across some continents to give
you an overview of where the
book and the story took me.
And then I'll open it up for
questions, and we can talk a
little bit more.
So this is an image
that I love--
really, really, really love.
It was photographed by a woman
named Jessica Hilltout in a
book called "Amen," and it was
during the last World Cup in
South Africa.
And she decided to look
at the other side
of the game of soccer.
So while all the fanfare was
happening in Johannesburg, she
went off into all these
villages in Africa.
And she gave out
soccer balls--
like nice, shiny Adidas
balls-- in return for
photographing the balls
that kids were
using in these villages.
And this is one of them made
from rags and twine.
The photos in this book
are just incredible.
One of the things that they
convey is this kind of desire
to play, the desire and the
passion around these objects--
the ball--
that whether you have the
technology, and you have the
money to purchase the latest
and greatest, you
figure out a way.
And it says a lot about the
spirit of the game.
I had to throw this in.
I realize 1,000,360,000 results
for "ball" is actually
a pretty good number.
I googled "God" right after
this, and it was only a few
hundred billion more
than ball.
So it clearly is a pretty
dominant theme
globally, I would say.
I would love your help
in moving my book up
the rankings here.
As you can see, they're
not close to the top.
So first of all, I decided to
start at the beginning, or
even before the beginning.
In other words, "why do we play
ball" starts with "why do
we play at all?" And
what is play?
And I found in my research
there's a lot of incredibly
interesting research
going on now--
scientific research--
around the importance of play,
not just socially, but also
psychologically,
developmentally,
especially for kids.
And a lot of this research is
focused on animals, because as
this great scholar Johan
Huizinga who wrote this
treatise on play in the early
20th century commented,
"Animals haven't waited for
man to teach them how to
play." So anybody who has a dog,
goes out and plays ball
with them, or has seen other
animals play knows that this
is really true, that
play is not
something that we invented.
It's something much deeper and
much more ancient than that.
So I went to Florida to a place
called Gulf World--
pretty quirky, old, kind of
falling apart marine park--
where I met a scientist named
Stan Kuczaj, who's originally
a psychologist and is now
a dolphin researcher.
And he's been studying, for
years, play among dolphins.
And he's found some really
interesting things.
One is that dolphins are
extremely playful,
particularly this one type
that he studied called
rough-toothed dolphins.
They use play as a way of
learning about the world and
testing their physical limits,
understanding the boundaries--
both the social boundaries
of their pod and their
relationship with
other dolphins--
but their physical boundaries in
terms of how to swim in the
wild and be safe and dodge
predators and be on the alert.
So he's done all these studies
that really indicate that play
for dolphins is a fundamental
part of their survival.
And this is interesting, and
this research is interesting,
because for years play was seen
as the opposite of what's
serious or work.
It was seen as something
frivolous, and scientists had
really struggled to find any
biological reason why any
animal should play.
In fact, if you really boil it
down, play often exposes
animals to danger.
It depletes their energy.
It puts them in precarious
situations, oftentimes, where
they're distracted.
So in many respects, play should
be the opposite of
something that selected for,
and yet it's selected for
again and again.
There's been some other really
interesting studies done with
rats where one group of rats
is separated from another.
One group is allowed to play
and encouraged to play with
frenzy, and the other is shut
out and apart from each other,
and they're not allowed
to play.
And over time, the
ones that are
playing develop a protein--
a neurotrophic factor-- that
actually stimulates the
prefrontal cortex, which is
where emotional intelligence
and decision making
originates.
So a lot of these studies are
showing that play actually
makes you smarter--
makes animals smarter and most
likely humans in the way it
helps us actually develop our
brains, our social skills, our
emotional intelligence.
So that was where the book
started, was what is play, and
where does it come from?
And there's a lot
more on that.
Sweeping through time--
so there's not much evidence
for ball play or sports,
obviously, among
hunter-gatherers in the
Paleolithic.
There's not much evidence for
much of anything in that
period except for some cave
paintings and stones and such.
But it's also not a stretch to
think that play and sports
probably originated
in the hunt.
When you think of the skills
that are involved in the hunt,
they're not that far from the
skills that ultimately are
involved in sports.
And even the tool kits of the
Paleolithic hunter-- the
spear, the rock, the net, the
throwing stone-- these are
things that you might find in a
sort of prehistoric sporting
goods store.
So there's not a stretch
to think that sports
evolved as a way of--
like the dolphins--
testing boundaries, of using
play as a way of honing skills
that would have more application
in real life, in
the hunt, in protecting
yourself and your
family, and so on.
But that's mostly speculation.
It's really not until the growth
of civilizations--
Mesopotamia and Egypt--
we actually start to see
evidence that they were
playing ball.
They were playing sports.
They had already begun to
worship this sacred orb, as I
often call it.
This is a depiction from a
tomb in Egypt, 1500 BC,
showing King Tuthmosis with a
ball in his left hand and a
stick the right and these
little servants
offering him new balls.
This particular scene is shown
again and again and again in
this period of ancient Egypt.
And it seems that there was an
actual ceremonial game played
by the pharaoh called
seker-hemat in which the ball
was struck into the
four directions.
It was seen as defeating the
serpent enemy of the gods.
There was a lot of mythology
around it and a lot of
ceremony around it.
It's the first time we find
archaeological balls in some
of these tombs.
Some of them are made
from papyrus.
Some of them are skin stuffed
with all kinds of materials.
There's even a kind of primitive
bowling set that was
found in a tomb of a young
boy during this time.
So we know that these games had
already started, already
had meaning in these cultures.
Of course, in ancient
Greece and
Rome these games continued.
The ancient Greeks played a game
called episkyros, which
was kind of like rugby.
There were anywhere from 12
to 15 people on a side.
It's hard to understand all of
the rules from the text, but
it's clear that they played
these sports.
They weren't part of
the Olympics, ever.
The Olympics were seen as
serious games for serious
warriors and athletes, whereas
ball games were seen as fun,
frivolous play, like
child's play.
So they were in two different
categories.
But they did play a lot
of ball sports.
Real organized sports in the Old
World really kick off in
around the 10th century
in England.
And that's when football,
broadly
speaking, hits the scene.
And when I talk about
football, I mean,
like, all of football--
American football,
soccer, rugby.
The root of all those games
goes back at least to
10th-century England.
And there's wonderful accounts
from the earliest periods of
the medieval era of these huge
mob games being played between
one village and another.
This is a depiction from the
early 19th century in the
Normandy region of France.
And it's hard to tell here, but
there's just basically an
enormous scrum going on
of hundreds of men
tousling over a ball.
And so for hundreds of years
through the medieval period,
this was happening in villages
all over Europe, where one
town or one parish would compete
against another.
They were, kind of as a holdover
to earlier times,
highly symbolic affairs with
religious connotations.
This game la soule, played in
France, the name is believed
to come from sol, or the sun.
And some of the beliefs were
that whichever side managed to
capture the ball in these
contests would ensure a good
harvest for their town or
their particular area.
Or in some cases, it was the
fisherman versus the farmers,
and if the fishermen
won, there would be
good fish that year.
So these were symbolic
affairs.
They were usually played
around feast
days like Mardi Gras--
so right before Lent--
kind of crazy affairs--
lots drinking, lots
of playing and carousing.
And that's really how football
started, which is not that far
from where it's ended up.
So this book that I wrote was
way more than history.
I've always liked to use
whatever I do as
an excuse to travel.
That's the only way I became an
archaeologist or have done
anything exciting in
my life is just
very, very into traveling.
So for this particular chapter
on football, I learned about a
holdover of this mob football
game that's played twice a
year on the island of Orkney,
north of Scotland, which is a
very cold, very remote,
kind of rocky place.
And on Christmas and New Year's
Day, the two sides of
town face off against each
other, just as they did in
medieval times.
The sides are known as the
uppies and the doonies,
because there's one street in
town called Post Office Lane,
which is probably from
here to that wall.
And if you're born on the
upper side of that, then
you're an uppie for
your whole life.
It's like being a Celtics fan
or Red Sox fan for life.
And if you're born on the other
side, you're a doonie,
because you're on the
downward side.
And there's no choice.
You don't put on a uniform.
You don't get to decide.
It's just that's the way you're
born, and that's your
side for life.
On these two days, all of the
men from town who are on one
side or another get out
in front of the
church at 1:00 PM.
An incredible handcrafted ball
made by the local shoemaker is
thrown from the front of the
church into this pack of men--
literally a sea of men.
And for the next six hours, they
struggle over this ball.
There's really no rules
to speak of.
There's unspoken rules
of etiquette.
But pretty much, it's just
a brutal affair.
And the objective is the uppies
have to take the ball
uptown and touch it to this
ancient wall at Mackinson's
Corner, and the doonies have to
go the other direction and
submerge it in the sea on the
downward side of town.
And other than that, it's
all hell breaks loose.
And it's one of the most
incredible affairs.
I'll hopefully show you at the
end a little clip so you can
get a better sense of it.
But this is how football
got started--
was really a kind of
tribal affair.
And this sense of belonging that
these men have and this
ritual that they go through
every year, it's not only a
game, but it literally
is kind of the
cornerstone of their culture.
If you took this game out
of it, they wouldn't
know what to do.
And that's how they speak of it,
is that kind of passion.
So it was really incredible to
be able to see that and it
does give you a sense of why
we play these games.
This is another scene.
You can see the church.
This is right after the ball
gets swallowed into the mouth
of the pack, as I
like to call it.
And you won't see that
ball, maybe, for
another couple of hours.
You'll see the scrum bouncing
off alleyways and making its
way through town, but it's
rare you see the ball.
All the shops and the streets
are barricaded very heavily,
because this pack will go right
through the windows otherwise.
The year I was there, there
was a guy who was a
flat-lander from London
or someplace who
came up to watch it.
And the poor guy left his
BMW on the street.
Like, he didn't know.
And the pack literally went up
and over this thing and just
squashed it.
And then they were fighting
over who was
going to pay for it.
And they were like, (SCOTTISH
ACCENT), oh,
it's an act of God.
So on from there.
So football began as
this mob sport.
It was the people's game from
the very beginning,
and it still is.
We think of the global expanse
of soccer, football, there's a
reason for that.
It has roots where everybody's
involved.
It brings everyone in.
Tennis developed in a completely
different way,
although in a similar
time frame.
So tennis has its roots in
13th-century France, and it
started in the monasteries,
interestingly.
The monks, who were busy
wearing hair shirts and
prostrating themselves, did
occasionally have fun.
And they invented this game of
tennis, which they called jeu
de paume because it was played
with the palm of the hand,
originally.
And for the first 200 years of
the game, there was no racket,
and there was no net.
It was basically a kind
of hand ball game.
But they played it
in the cloisters.
And the depiction on the left is
actually from the 1600s in
Paris of one of these
jeu de paume courts.
And you can see if you think of
your history books and what
a medieval courtyard
would look like.
It's got these sloping
penthouses and these galleys
on the side and a kind
of courtyard.
So the court, as it's evolved
through time and as it's still
played today, reflects this.
On the right is one of these
jeu de paume courts.
In the US it's called court
tennis, and in England it's
called real tennis.
And you can see it hasn't
changed much.
Still got the penthouses, still
got these galleys and
these unusual lines for
how you score points.
So tennis began as a monastic
sport, but then the princes of
the neighboring area were, of
course, being educated in the
monasteries.
So it quickly became
the sport of kings.
It was an elite sport.
Shakespeare wrote about
it many, many times.
Through the 1500's and 1600's,
it was the absolute rage on
the royal circuit to the extent
where there were 250 of
these rather enormous,
substantial courts in Paris
alone in that time period.
Today, there is exactly one in
Paris, which I went to, and
one on the outskirts of Paris.
This one on the right is at the
Chateau de Fontainebleau,
which is one of the palaces
of the French kings.
And I got a lesson in how to
play this ancient form of
tennis and come to appreciate
it at the same time.
One of the cool things about
this game-- there are are many
cool things about it--
first of all, that it's
even still surviving.
There's, I think, 45 courts left
in the world where you
can actually play this game.
One of them is in Boston
on Boylston Street,
and I played there.
This is from the 1600s, showing
there was an actual
person called a paumier who was
responsible for making the
balls and the racquets,
kind of a court pro.
And they still exist.
And this guy [? Mattie, ?]
who I spent time with in
Fontainebleau still makes
the balls by hand.
You can see, essentially, the
same technique, the same
technology--
very simple, very primitive,
you can say.
But that's part of the art of
the game is the fact that you
go to a court where somebody
can make the balls just the
way you like them.
And that's a real skill
that is, frankly,
dying and dying fast.
OK, you're going to have some
travel whiplash here, but at
the same time tennis was
exploding in Europe, of
course, Europeans were heading
to the New World to conquer
and create mayhem, among
other things.
And they arrived full of their
game, and they had other balls
that were filled with wind.
And they brought those
with them.
Columbus, on his second
voyage, brought
some of these balls.
And they arrived in
the New World and
in the Yucatan region.
And they encountered the
Maya Indians and
the Aztecs, of course.
And they were shocked to find
that there was a sport being
played there that was quite
sophisticated, and even more
shocked to find that they were
playing with this substance
that they'd never seen before,
that they thought was
possessed by demons.
Because the substance would
bounce 12 feet in the air,
ricochet off walls, and had
this life in it which was
perplexing to them.
They had never seen anything
like it-- of
course, it was rubber--
because they never encountered
rubber before.
It was indigenous to Mexico
and Central America.
The Maya, and the Olmec before
them, had been playing this
sophisticated sport with this
solid rubber ball for, at that
point, almost 2,000 years.
The earliest ball courts that
look like this date
to about 1200 BC.
So at the same time those
Egyptians were playing their
games, which were kind of
ceremonial, the Maya, the
Aztecs, and their predecessors
were playing what was actually
a much more sophisticated
and complex and
very athletic game.
The game today is
called ulama.
So that's the name that I
usually use to talk about it.
It was played in a
court like this--
lots of different shapes, but
usually an alleyway where the
actual play happened
between two teams.
There is a lot of different
kinds of markers, but here you
can see rings fairly high up.
The object to the game was to
knock this rubber ball usually
with your hips, sometimes with
your forearm padded, through
one of these rings and otherwise
score points.
This is a depiction, from a Maya
polychrome vase that's
been rolled out by a
photographer, that shows one
of these games in action.
So you see these players
in motion.
You see them against a temple
behind them with musicians,
and it's this big ceremony.
And so a lot of the depictions
of this game that we see are
highly ceremonial.
And in fact, we see enough of
these to come to understand
that there was life and death
consequences associated with
this game, and that at least in
some of these rituals, most
likely the losers lost their
heads, quite literally.
So this is a depiction from a
site called Chichen Itza in
the Yucatan Peninsula.
I don't know if anyone's
ever been there.
Yeah.
It's a pretty widely touristed
site, and they have this
enormous ball court there,
which is kind of Madison
Square Garden-scale
ball court.
And on the side in stone
is this carving
that shows two players.
One of them is standing on the
left with a knife in his hand
made of stone and a head
in his left hand.
And on the right is a player
whose head has been
decapitated, and out
of it sprouts
serpents and squash plants.
And in between is the
ball, but the ball
is shown as a skull.
So there's this symbolism.
And we see these kinds of
depictions again and again.
And clearly, there was a very
symbolic connection between
playing this game, the sacrifice
of the loser-- or
the captive, if there was
warfare leading up to this--
and the offering to the gods.
And it was believed that--
with these squash plants
you'll see--
through this act, you
regenerated the cosmos.
This was part of this
ritual cycle of the
Maya and the Aztecs.
And it was just a fundamental
part of their religion--
a lot more than just
a ball game.
I spent time in this small
village in West Mexico.
There's only about 100 people
who still play this game.
It's the oldest continuous
sport in the world.
And they still make these
rubber balls.
You can see a player
there leaping to
connect with a ball.
But this game is dying, in part
because with development,
it's really hard to
get the rubber.
And a lot of the rubber
plantations are located in
areas that are dominated
by narcotraficos.
So if you want a ball, you might
pay for it with your
head or other body parts.
So unfortunately, this
game is dying--
dying quickly.
So then I looked from there at
lacrosse, which was a chapter
which I won't talk about.
But I got into baseball,
because it has been our
national pastime.
And I wanted to understand,
how does a game become a
national pastime, and what
does that actually mean?
Some form of hitting a ball
with a bat goes way back.
This is a French medieval
document from 1301 that shows
a pretty good line drive
happening in
the lower left there.
So clearly, hitting a ball
with a bat is not that
sophisticated a thing to do.
There were probably cavemen
doing that.
Doesn't necessarily make
the game baseball,
but it has deep roots.
But the game really emerged in
England, again, much to the
chagrin of nationalist
Americans.
This is one of the first
depictions of a game described
as baseball, with two
words, from 1744.
And this is actually a woodcut
from a children's book by John
Newbery, for whom the Newbery
Medal is named after.
And it was just a silly little
story about little kids, but
they're playing an early
version of baseball.
Again, in this case, they're
using their hand, because back
then it was like, if you had
a bat, you had a bat.
If you didn't, you hit
it with your hand.
But you can see the three stones
that were used as bases
and this guy on the left
who's pitching it.
And they describe in there that
the idea of the game is
to strike the ball and then run
the bases in the circuit.
And the way you got somebody
out was to soak them, which
means you hit them
with the ball.
And baseball's rules,
originally, were all about
getting soaked by the ball.
It was only in the late 1850s
that they changed that rule,
because it was becoming more of
a grown up game, and people
didn't want to get hit by the
ball every time they ran to
first base.
But the interesting thing about
baseball is that it
really started as a
children's game.
It was not taken seriously until
some local businessmen
in New York in the 1840s started
playing it on their
breaks from work and started
putting rules around it and
turning it into a real sport.
And one of the interesting
stories in baseball that I
researched is around this man.
I don't know if anybody
knows who this is.
AUDIENCE: Cartwright.
JOHN FOX: This is Doubleday.
Yeah, Abner Doubleday,
Cartwright is the real father
of baseball.
So Abner Doubleday, who's long
been held up as the father of
baseball, invented in a cow
pasture in Cooperstown in
1839, the whole story is
essentially made up.
And the story of how this story
came to be is pretty
interesting and speaks to the
desire for a national game.
The brief version is that
Albert Spalding--
AG Spalding--
of Spalding Sporting Goods
now was a great pitcher--
pitched with the Red Stockings,
pitched with the
White Stockings, and was
manager, was one of the stars
of his age, basically,
in the mid-19th
century, late 19th century.
But he had bigger aspirations.
He started to see that this
baseball thing had traction,
and he had the instincts
of a businessman.
So he started Spalding Sporting
Goods and very
rapidly became incredibly
successful business.
He just monopolized the sporting
goods industry.
And so he became kind of the
father of the game, like,
marshaling it along, and turning
it into a real sport,
and evangelizing it.
And around that time, this
controversy had been swirling
about, where did baseball
originate?
It's the ultimate
American game.
It's the era of Manifest
Destiny, and
America needed a game.
Unfortunately, the reality was
that a lot of the experts of
the time knew that this game
had English roots.
And so there was a lot of
controversy around, well, was
it really from England,
or was that a
separate, different game?
And was it really an
American invention,
like all good things?
So Albert Spalding, in 1905,
actually formed a national
committee to research
baseball's origins.
And he put out ads in newspapers
far and wide.
And a letter came into a
newspaper in Ohio from this
guy named Abner Graves--
just random guy-- saying,
basically, I was there when
baseball was invented.
And it was by the Civil War
hero Abner Doubleday.
We were playing marbles in a
cow pasture, and Doubleday
came up, and he scratched out
the diamond in the sand, and
he showed us how to play it.
And that was that.
And that was good enough
for Spalding.
There was no other evidence,
and he essentially declared
that the game was invented
in Cooperstown in 1839.
And most people were fine with
that, because it fit the time
period-- that idea of invention
and Manifest Destiny
around sport.
Unfortunately, there
is no evidence to
support that at all.
In fact, Doubleday, when he was
supposed to be inventing
baseball, was at West
Point, which is more
than 100 miles away.
And all the records show
that he never left
during that time period.
He left behind like
67 diaries--
never mentions baseball once
in all of his diaries.
And this guy, Abner Graves,
who concocted this story,
ended up being a complete
nut job.
He claimed to have been on the
Pony Express like 10 years
before the Pony Express
had started.
He ended up killing his wife and
spending his final years
in an insane asylum.
But even as recently as four
years ago, I think, Bud Selig,
who is the Major League Baseball
commissioner, said
that he still believed
that Abner Doubleday
had invented baseball.
So it just shows you these
nationalist myths die hard.
American football--
so where we left football was in
the alleyways of Orkney and
this mob game, the medieval game
that was being played.
That went on for some years,
but football was a
troublemaker sport
from day one.
People were getting mauled and
killed, and property was being
broken in these big
mob scrums.
In the 15th century alone, the
game was banned like nine
times by the English kings.
You couldn't play it
within London,
because it was too dangerous.
So this game, from the very
beginning, was kind of marked.
People had an issue with it, so
much so that with all these
bannings, there was a period
in the 1600s to the early
1800s where the game
was dying off.
It just wasn't played
that widely.
And where it was kept alive was
in the public schools of
England-- what we think of
as private schools--
these little schools like Eton
and Rugby where these elite
kids were educated.
And one writer described these
places as the "ludic zoos of
the age," because this is where
these games that would
have died otherwise were
preserved by these scrappy
kids, basically.
And what happened in those
schools is different versions
of football developed.
So at Eton, they developed a
game that was focused more
around kicking and keeping
the ball low.
And at Rugby, where they had
this huge expanse of green,
they developed a running
and carrying game,
which involved tackling.
So you had these different
kinds of games.
Some of them allowed tackling
and holding and running with
ball, and others didn't.
And there was just kind of
a mishmash of sports.
And it was really here in the
late 19th century that these
sports started to
get codified.
So soccer--
association football--
in the 1860s got its rules.
And it looked like America was
going down the path of more of
a soccer type of sport.
And it was actually Harvard that
intervened, because all
of the local Ivy League schools
had banded together
and said, we're going
to codify rules.
You can't tackle.
You can't carry the ball.
And Harvard said, we're out.
We're not playing by those
rules, because we've been
playing for years by
these Boston rules.
And the Boston rules allow ball
handling and tackling
under certain circumstances.
And they eventually
had their way.
They eventually imposed their
will over this commission, and
American football evolved
as the physical
game that it is today.
But what I always find
interesting is people talk
about Americans as rejecting
the global game of soccer,
which I don't think is the case,
because soccer didn't
really exist at all until
the 1860s as a game
with its own rules.
By that time, we were already
incubating other
versions of the game.
So it was really more a case
that we had a form of the game
that we liked, and that by the
time soccer became anywhere
near a global game, we were
already doing our own thing.
And Americans do have that
independent streak, so we
weren't about to reverse
history and go back.
To cover football, I went out to
Ohio to the one factory in
this place called Ada where they
produce every football
that's used in the NFL and
have since the 1950s.
So basically, 150 workers in
this old-school factory that
hand make these footballs with,
again, pretty basic
machinery, which was
pretty cool.
I learned that it takes five
cows to service a single NFL
game, if you add up the leather
involved and where the
leather comes from.
So I always found that
a fun little fact.
So I got to see how this was
produced and learn about the
whole way that football took
this rough game of soccer or
rugby and created this
incredibly disciplined game
with incredibly sophisticated
rules over a pretty brief
period of time.
But unfortunately--
or fortunately, depending
on how you roll--
it never shook off the
violence at its core.
[SNEEZE]
JOHN FOX: Bless you.
And in fact, with every rule
that was laid down to control
the violence early on, the
game got more violent.
So early on, there were
these massive scrums
and these mass plays--
flying wedges and other plays
designed to essentially mow
down the other team with full
brute force so badly that
early on, one year there was
something like 14 college
players who died on the field
playing football.
There were no helmets.
So it was a brutal game.
Teddy Roosevelt formed a
commission around it, because
there were schools who
were banning it.
So this was a theme that goes
back centuries for football.
And of course, the theme
is still with us today.
In fact, I think it
comes in cycles.
And in recent years, of course,
there's been a lot of
talk about brain damage
from concussions.
This is actually from--
some of you guys, I'm sure,
played "Madden," or still do.
But this is from an earlier
version where, when there was
an injury, the ambulance would
come out and run over all the
players, which was
kind of funny.
But this violence is still with
the game and in recent
years has become, of course,
really controversial.
This is a suicide note from
Dave Duerson, who was a
Pro-Bowl Chicago Bears, then
New York Giants, two-time
Super Bowl winner who is
believed to have suffered from
this disease--
chronic traumatic
encephalopathy, which is
caused by repeated
concussions.
Science is still not 100%,
but it's believed
to cause this condition.
And he was severely depressed
and abusive to his family and
ended up killing himself.
But he didn't shoot himself
in the head.
He shot himself in the chest and
left a note to say, please
see that my brain is given to
the NFL bank, because he
believed that it was because
of football that he was not
feeling like himself.
And of course, now there's 200
lawsuits in the NFL, and a lot
of parents aren't letting
their kids
play high school ball.
There's some terrible stories
from Western Mass recently
about concussions in games.
So it's become more and
more of an issue.
And finally--
and I'll drop off here--
I looked at basketball, which
is my favorite game,
personally.
And I love this story just
because it is the one sport
that we play today that was
invented from whole cloth in
Springfield, Mass by this
guy James Naismith.
And all these other games
evolved over centuries, and
this one was really, truly
invented and in a matter of a
few years had spread globally
through the YMCA, which is
where the game originally
was invented.
And one of the things I talk
about in the book--
because unfortunately, a lot of
history of sports is about
men, like a lot of history--
this game very quickly--
like literally within a year--
got completely taken over by
women, who realized that it
was a game they could play.
It wasn't highly physical.
It was skill based.
It was good exercise.
And this is a wonderful image
from Smith College from about
1894 showing women trying to
play the game in these long
petticoats.
So that's the whirl
of this book.
And you'd have to read the book
to find out if I ever got
an answer to my son's question
of why we play ball.
It's one of those questions that
there's certainly not a
single answer to.
But I think over the course of
these trips and these chapters
that I hopefully was able to
distill some of the things
that make these games
so important to us.
And part of it for me was being
able to convey that to
my son, to be focused on the
things that matter, rather
than all the other stuff that
doesn't matter that we read
about in the papers.
I do want to mention--
and then I'll take questions--
that we're making a
documentary about
this right now--
I've got a clip, but I'd
rather open it up for
questions if there are any--
which hopefully will
be out in the fall.
And it's called "Bounce: How the
Ball Taught the World to
Play."
And we've been shooting in
different locations.
We're going to Mexico next
month to film ulama.
We're working with two great
filmmaker friends of mine who
are using this incredible
camera, and so far, the
footage looks wonderful.
And it's basically a cinematic
exploration of the ball and
global passions for sports.
So look for that hopefully
next year.
That's it.
I'll take questions, thoughts,
whatever you got.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Who won, the uppies
or the doonies?
JOHN FOX: Oh, good question.
So when I got there, I found
that if you're born there, it
depends which side of Post
Office Lane you're born.
But of course, there's a lot
of people who come from
outside who watch this game.
And you, as visitor, also have
to be an uppie or a doonie.
So they devise these very
elaborate rules.
It's wherever you set
foot in town first--
which side you first
set foot on--
determines, again, whether
you're an uppie or
a doonie for life.
So I ended up setting foot
on the doonie side.
That's where I got out of the
taxi in front of my B&B.
And I was psyched, and I was
talking to all these doonies
and feeling like one of them,
and then I found out that they
hadn't won in like 12 years.
So I was instantly a member
of a losing franchise.
But they won for the first
time in 12 years.
And it wasn't because I did
anything, unless I have some
great luck.
But it made it all the more
exciting, because I was
literally hanging out with these
losers for two days and
interviewing them.
And I'm like, yeah, but they're
going to lose, and
that's no good.
And then they won, I was like,
oh, this is a great story.
So now I'm a doonie for life.
AUDIENCE: I was just going to
ask if you know why it's
called pigskin.
JOHN FOX: Yeah, so it's called
pigskin because the early
balls used for football and
other games were basically
inflated pig bladders.
They didn't have
rubber until--
well, the Mayans had invented it
years before, but we didn't
figure it out until Goodyear
created vulcanization.
So they actually were made of
pig skin, and that's where
that term "pigskin"
comes from.
So the outside has pretty much
always been cow skin, but it's
still got that name
stuck with it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did you see any
trends over time in the
rewards for the games?
Like all this competitiveness
goes towards [? a cause ?]
like winning, and you get
credibility or pride.
But over time, in your study,
did you find that--
with the Mayans, you were
talking about it was literally
life or death.
The gladiator games, and now
we've moved towards a little
more mediated version of that.
JOHN FOX: Yeah, well, it's
an interesting question.
One of the things that I found
interesting is that very early
on in these ancient games, the
object of most of the games
seemed to be to capture a
ball and bring it back
to your home territory.
And it seemed to have, again,
this symbolism around the
capture of the hunt, of the
prey, or agriculturally, of
the Sun and the symbolism
around that.
And then it shifted at some
point from capturing something
to essentially invading enemy
territory, which is what a lot
of our games are.
It's about penetrating the
defense and scoring a goal.
So there's that, and somewhere I
think there's an interesting
thing that happened, and we
moved toward the invasion of
enemy territory.
I think in terms of the actual
bounty, obviously, one of the
biggest ones was the idea of
getting paid to play the game.
And that was a huge controversy
in most of these
sports in the 19th century.
Lacrosse was an interesting
example because lacrosse, of
course, was originally a
Native American game.
And it was in Montreal where the
Native Americans, who were
on reservations there,
introduced this game to some
of the Westerners there who
thought it was a pretty cool
game, and they started
playing it, too.
But of course, the Indians in
the surrounding communities
were way better than the
white guys who were
playing this game.
There was no contest.
But the Indians were
dirt poor.
They had no money, and so these
white clubs would start
paying these Indians to play.
But then they were considered
ringers.
So then they established rules,
effectively, that no
Indian could play lacrosse in
any of these circuits and any
of these clubs.
So the Indians were literally,
during that period, banned
from playing their own game.
And it was largely because they
were seen as violating
this kind of amateur code and
getting paid for it, even
though they were just
trying to survive.
And there's a lot of
stories like that--
that period of time where the
people were really grappling
with this idea of sports being
gentlemen's games played for
love of nation or amateur ideals
versus getting paid.
And obviously, that all kind of
got blown up along the way.
But I think it's still with us
when you see debates around
NCAA and college football.
There's still a lot
of that around.
Like, what's right?
What's wrong?
What's too much?
What are the right reasons
to play and the
wrong reasons to play?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So now we see all
these games as competition.
But you talked about,
originally, some of them were
played in monasteries
and stuff.
Was it still a competition, or
was there some higher goal?
Can you talk about what's
the purpose, somehow?
JOHN FOX: Yeah, that's a
good question, because
I think it's true.
I think competition's been
probably part of it all along,
but there was much more of an
emphasis on shared outcomes.
I would say in my view, even
with the Kirkwall Ba'--
the crazy game in Orkney--
even though there's ferocious
competition and there's a
winner and a loser, the object
of that game is the game.
The object of that game is to
perpetuate this tradition and
the rules around it, which are
the founding rules of that
social order.
To me, that's like the
goal of that game.
And the fact that there are
winners and losers is
essential to creating the
dynamic of a good sport.
But it's not what
it's all about.
And at the end of the day,
these guys are like--
and I interviewed lots of
people-- they were like, it's
how you play the game.
And they don't say it like your
kid's coach does, which
is kind of a truism.
But they say it with complete
conviction.
This is what it's all about.
It's about keeping
this thing alive.
So I think those two things
can co-exist.
I think it's more like
a sliding scale.
I would say we've kind of slid
off maybe one end of that
scale these days with
a lot of sports.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sort of curious--
how did the spectator,
who observes without
participating, come about?
How long has that been around?
JOHN FOX: That's a
good question.
I mean, if you look at football,
it really was-- at
least for men--
it was pretty much all in.
When you see these scrums, and
you see these big games,
everybody played a role.
And even in Orkney, you'd see
these 80-year-old men who
wouldn't be the guy in the
middle of the scrum--
because their wives would
kill them, even though
they want to be there.
But they'd be the guys on the
outside of the pack calling
the moves and strategizing--
not coaches, but very
much players.
And I think that goes back
to medieval times.
I think tennis actually started
to break that down a
little bit.
And part of it is you have these
galleys, and it was this
kind of elite, royal game.
So ladies would sit on the
edges, and people would
gather, and it would be kind
of a society affair.
And then getting into the 19th
century, then, of course,
people started to figure
out that you could
pay for these things.
So I think it started probably
pretty early on, but it
started in some sports and
not in other sports,
interestingly.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It seems like what
happens in the [? arcades ?]
is very much something that
binds a town together.
And what strikes me as odd is
that that's not more common--
that you don't see that in
more-- especially small--
communities.
Why is that?
Why are there not more of these
kind of examples of
community games that bring
towns together?
JOHN FOX: Yeah, I don't know.
I know what you mean.
I'm not sure I agree 100%.
I think there are obviously a
lot of communities that are
really brought together
by their home team.
I mean, especially college
football--
it's crazy.
There was a study down
in Tennessee--
a sociological study.
After family, football came
before church in Tennessee as
the most important thing
to people there.
But of course, there,
it's very much my
team versus your team.
But I think those things still
exist in some communities.
I just think in a place like
Orkney, they've literally
worked really hard at this.
First of all, it's like a tiny
rock out in the ocean.
So it's been kind of protected
from the ways of the rest of
the world for some time.
So I guess it's been able to
sort of live in its bubble,
whereas in other places, people
are coming and going.
People are transient.
People are trying to make
money off things.
It just changes the dynamic
through time.
I don't know.
That's what I'm guessing.
You had a question, sir.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just a small
terminology correction.
Sorry.
The Smith College women's
basketball team
were wearing bloomers--
JOHN FOX: Oh, bloomers, OK.
AUDIENCE: --which were a late
19th-century invention for
women's athletics.
JOHN FOX: They were, indeed.
Good call.
They were not wearing Spandex
or other useful
materials for play.
Good.
All right, well thank
you guys very much.
[APPLAUSE]